[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi à
21 septembre et dans les titres de
l'actualité locale le premier tour de la
législative partielle a livré son
verdict dans la 11e circonscription
le candidat les républicains philippe
benassaya arrive en tête devant sandrine
grands groupes pour génération europe
ecologie les verts en revanche en ne se
qualifiant pas pour le deuxième tour la
république en marche vers cette
circonscription gagnée en 2010 cette
analyse les yvelines à l'heure du
cyclisme ce week-end mantes-la-jolie
accueillait hier le départ de la
dernière étape du tour de france malgré
le contexte sanitaire le public a pu
apercevoir les coureurs et la caravane
de l'événement et puis retour sur les
journées européennes du patrimoine un
rendez vous forcément particulier cette
année avec l'épidémie de kobe 2009 et de
nombreuses animations se dérouler tout
de même à saint quentin en yvelines ou
encore à montfort l'amaury qui
accueillait un rassemblement autour de
l'automobile est à la une de l'actualité
et locales dans l'actualité du jour 20
centres de dépistage et de diagnostic ou
qu'ovide 19 qui ouvre progressivement en
ile-de-france déployés par l' agence
régionale de santé est de 6 dans chaque
département de la région dans les
yvelines on l'a appris aujourd'hui ils
sont situés à trappes et mantes la jolie
et sont déjà opérationnels objectif
désengorger un maximum les laboratoires
pour la réalisation de tests pcr dont le
résultat c est connue dont les résultats
sont connus en 24 heures est d'ailleurs
à mantes la jolie
le centre de dépistage a été inauguré
cet après midi en présence du ministre
de la santé
olivier ferrand la structure est au 10
avenue du président franklin roosevelt
est géré par le laboratoire cerba
alliance attrape les équipes du
laboratoire eurofins biomnis sont
installés aux quatre allers antoine de
saint-exupéry comme tous les autres
cycles soit entre up est ouvert de 8h à
14h et uniquement au public prioritaire
dans un premier temps il faut être muni
d'une ordonnance ou d'un justificatif de
la rs précisant que vous êtes
symptomatique ou cas contacts et dès
cette semaine 150 tests pcr pourront
être réalisés chaque jour 200 aides dès
la semaine prochaine l'objectif étant
d'atteindre les 500 tests par jour le
centre de dépistage sera ouvert jusqu'à
la fin mars à l'école maternelle et
élémentaire le protocole kobe 19 va être
allégé et ce dès demain annonce du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
désormais pour
envisager la fermeture d'une classe
voire d'une école il faut qu'au moins
trois élèves soient positifs au virus
contre 1 actuellement
l enseignant s'il est bien masqué et les
autres élèves ne sont plus considérés
comme cas contacts cette décision
s'appuie sur un avis rendu par le haut
conseil pour la santé publique affirmant
que les enfants sont peu à risque et peu
actif dans la transmission du virus et
aux derniers chiffres remontant à
vendredi
l'éducation nationale dans l'académie de
versailles annonce deux écoles dans les
yvelines qui ont fermé leurs portes pour
raison de kovy 19 dans l'actualité
également en ce dimanche les électeurs
de la 11e circonscription des yvelines
étaient appelés aux urnes premier tour
de la législative partielle pour
désigner le nouveau député après la
démission de nadia est entré au
gouvernement en juillet dernier onze
candidats étaient en lice et le second
tour verra le retour du clivage gauche
droite ont fait le point avec mélanie
poké comme un air de 2012 le premier
tour de cette législative partielle
remet au goût du jour le clivage gauche
droite dans la 11e circonscription c'est
le candidat de la droite qui vire en
tête philippe benassaya recueillent 36%
des suffrages
on peut regretter bien sûr l'abstention
la faible participation
c'est une législative partielle qui
tombe assez mal je vais continuer dans
ce centre de tours ma présence sur le
terrain en sort d'un épisode quand même
un peu malheureux sur cette 11e
circonscription
je voudrais redonner une image de
terrain et une image assez proche de nos
concitoyens c'est important d'envoyer à
l'assemblée nationale des élus locaux
des acteurs locaux qu'ils sachent gérer
des projets et et qui ont fait leurs
preuves et qui ont obtenu des résultats
face au maire de bois d'arcy sandrine
grand gang la première adjointe de la
ville de trappes obtient près de 25%
candidats rupo attention pas beaucoup de
latitude pour ce que pouvait être le
résultat
et puis des basques dans certaines
villes évidemment qu'on rattrape mais
aussi l'encours et éléments de cette
session les messages qu'on a commencé à
envoyer ont été entendus le parti
présidentiel lui ne confirme pas le
scrutin de deux
17 remporté par nadia et pierre luc le
candidat ait l'air om n'est pas qualifié
pour le second tour
le délégué départemental ne récolte que
15% des suffrages
je sais pas avait attribué le résultat
uniquement à l'action ou l'inaction de
gouvernement ou de mouvements sera
peut-être un peu égocentrique je pense
qu'il faut regarder aussi du côté de la
campagne quelques minutes par les autres
points il est évidemment s'interroger si
on prend le projet et les malins on a
des trous arrivé en quatrième position
le rassemblement national obtient 7% un
score similaire au scrutin de 2010 est
nous l'avons vu au moment des
municipales une électorat est beaucoup
plus rétifs à se déplacer aux urnes
demain
de par le contexte sanitaire donc
finalement nous fermions que cette
élection serait très difficile pour nous
sur ce territoire là mais finalement
nous sommes dans les niveaux qu'on
pourrait attendre un scrutin marqué par
l'abstention seulement 17% des inscrits
se sont déplacés dans les bureaux de
vote
le second tour est prévu dimanche 27
septembre et vous l'avez vu la
république en marché son candidat pierre
lui ce ne seront pas au deuxième tour du
scrutin le parti présidentiel perd donc
cette circonscription ont gagné en 2017
par nadia pour parler de ce résultat
marie le bec est avec moi par visio
bonsoir ça va être la député de la 4e
circonscription des yvelines première
vice-présidente du groupe
la république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale un député un député de la
majorité présidentielle en moins dans
les yvelines
on rappelle qu'en 2017 il y avait une
vague de la république en marche avec
onze circonscriptions et gagner sur les
douze dans le département comment vous
analysez déjà ce résultat la perte déjà
de cette circonscription
on déplore toujours effectivement le
fait de perdre une élection mais il faut
bien noter que cette élection à la
hausse il y eu dans ce contexte
particulier celui d'une part c'est d'une
partielle ou c'est toujours plus
difficile de mobiliser et on voit bien
d'ailleurs que l'abstention hier a été
particulièrement
mon forte et ça doit aussi nous inviter
à toujours plus et a continué notre
notre action sur le terrain parce qu'on
perd une circonscription que la
république en marche ne sera pas
présente dans les villes d'ailleurs on
vous le dit à la participation qui
n'atteint pas les 20% si on élargit aux
autres scrutins d'aidé partiel 1 qui se
déroulait en france il y en avait cinq
autres aucun candidat de la république
en marche ne se qualifie pour le second
tour à chaque fois est ce qu'il faut et
au pas aussi y voir un vote sanction de
la politique des manuels emmanuel macron
pas votre avis non je ne crois pas
puisque on sait bien que les élections
intermédiaires sont souvent plus
difficiles pour la majorité qui est en
place et puis il faut aussi noter que
dans les élections qui ont eu lieu hier
seuls 3 des circonscriptions avaient un
parlementaire la république en marche
comme comme sortant pour les autres nous
n'étions nous n'étions pas présents ce
qui est aussi rajoute du challenge dans
la conquête de ces de ces
circonscriptions mais de toute évidence
ça veut dire que l'on doit continuer à
expliquer notre projet est d'ailleurs à
ce titre au pire lui cela très bien fait
dans le cadre de sa campagne il a
défendu le projet le contexte était et
est particulièrement compliqué nous
sommes aussi dans une situation
nationale qui a un peu inquiété un
certain nombre de français mais je ne
crois pas pour autant qu'il faille en
tirer un bilan surtout sur seulement 1,6
hier pense qu'avec un contexte aussi
particulier particulièrement sur cette
11e circonscription nadia été obligé de
démissionner pour entrer au gouvernement
elle est ministre délégué à la ville son
suppléant avaient été empêchées puisque
impliqué dans une afrique affaire de
trafic de drogue international
est-ce que ça a pu jouer à votre avis
est ce que pierre luce ne partait
finalement pas défavorisés mais dans
cette élection
écoutez moi j'ai accompagné pierre luce
sur le terrain dans le cadre de sa
campagne
lui même a défendu le bilan qui avait
été fait par un adia et je vous confirme
aussi qu'un certain nombre d'acteurs a
notamment d'acteurs institutionnels
qu'on a pu rencontrer à l'occasion de
cette campagne nous aussi confirmé
l'engagement de
nadia sur le territoire dans
l'accompagnement des entreprises dans
tous le sujet autour de la politique de
la ville et ceux menés c'est ce qui est
aussi explique sa nomination au
gouvernement
donc je ne crois pas que ce soit le
bilan de nadia et qu'ils soient remis en
question ici puisqu'elle a été très
mobilisés sur le terrain tout en étant
très dynamique à l'assemblée nationale
puisque l exercer un certain angle de
responsabilité dans son mandat de
parlementaire et elle est aussi membre
de la commission des finances qu'il ya
une condition que vous savez qui est
particulièrement dynamique à l'assemblée
nous c'est vrai que nous sommes déçus
par ce résultat même si l'usc les 15% ce
qui est un score honorable mais avec les
parfois chausse-trappes d'une élection
partielle auxquels il a fallu rappeler
mauvaise nouvelle n'arrive jamais seule
ce matin on a appris la démission aussi
de du numéro deux de la république en
marche pierre person qui a démissionné
de ses fonctions de délégué général
adjoint il reste tout de même militant
au sein du parti
il reproche à la république en inde être
trop rester dans cette dynamique de 2017
à savoir faire élire emmanuel macron et
que le parti elle ne produit aujourd'hui
plus d'idées est ce que c'est un constat
que vous dressez aussi est-ce que le le
parti finalement n'arrivent pas à bout
de souffle
on était un mouvement avec une base
militante très importante mais si un
mouvement qui était jeune et ça nous
invite aussi à devoir nous re penser en
permanence
parfois il y peut y avoir un peu des
remises en questions sont légitimes
à mi-chemin du quinquennat mais je crois
que c'est ce que précise perd pas son
d'ensemble interview c'est absolument
pas une question de personne de
personnalités d'ailleurs ça une espèce
guérini est très engagé dans la vie du
mouvement est bien un ensemble de
challenge pierre personnes ont estimé
que peut-être il n'était plus le
meilleur pour conduire cette
transformation et ce sont d'autres
personnalités qui ses fonctions mais
c'est sûr que on a inventé jeunes il
faut aussi savoir sans cesse se
repositionner et répond aux attentes et
des militants et qu'est-ce que peut
attendre plus largement nos concitoyens
sur la production d'idées le challenge
peut être aussi retrouver promouvoir
l'unité au sein du groupe l
même à l'assemblée nationale on sait que
c'est un groupe qui a perdu à des
députés depuis 2010 est j'en avais 314
en 2017
vous êtes aujourd'hui 275 c'est un mot
affiché sa aujourd'hui l'unité au sein
du groupe
oui c'est important et c'est ce sur quoi
christophe castaner là moi même qui est
un binôme dans le cadre de
renouvellement du président du groupe à
l'assemblée
nous avons fait campagne appelé au
rassemblement appelé à l'apaisement
après il ne faut pas non plus faire un
drame de ces départs il faut être dans
le cadre de la vie d'un groupe
parlementaire
il faut accepter le fait que peut-être
un certain moment certains ne se
reconnaissent plus dans les choix qui
peuvent être portés par le groupe charge
à christophe et moi même d'aller voir
ces députés aussi de leur montrer que
ils ont toute leur place et qu'elles
sont le bienvenu s'il souhaiterait
intégrer l'euro majoritaire un dernier
mot sur les yvelines l'objectif même
avec un député en moins c'est de
continuer à travailler ensemble tous les
députés de la majorité présidentielle et
de votre allié du modem c'est de
continuer ce travail
oui bien sûr depuis trois ans maintenant
on a vraiment une
une action de terrain qui est très forte
avec beaucoup de parlementaires qui sont
présents pour porter des projets pour
relayer la politique du gouvernement
et ça se fait très bien et en très bonne
intelligence avec le modem mais je crois
que c'est important
il ya dans le rôle du député les lois
qu'on vote à l'assemblée le contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement bien sûr mais
aussi le portage politique des réformes
que nous conduisons et je pense que
c'est très important qu'il faut pas
renoncer au terrain merci marie le bec
député la république en marge de la 4ème
circonscription des yvelines et je
précise que vous êtes également la
première vice-présidente du groupe mrm à
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
et j'ajoute que pour ces élections
législatives partielles le parti
socialiste des yvelines a apporté son
soutien à la candidate sandrine grands
groupes qui est arrivé vous l'avez vu
deuxième de ce scrutin au premier tour
le candidat de france écologie
jérémy bizet lui apporte son soutien à
l'autre candidat philippe benassaya et
brigitte bourguignon en visite dans les
yvelines ce lundi la ministre déléguée
en charge de l'autonomie s'est rendu
notamment à la maison
intergénérationnelle de jouy en josas
elle a échangé avec les différents
acteurs de ce site une résidence où
vivent des jeunes des personnes âgées
des mères célibataires avec cet objectif
de partager des moments de vie commun à
un mode d'abitain pour lutter contre
l'isolément et développer une solidarité
entre générations écoutez à ce propos la
ministre brigitte bourguignon interrogé
par nicolas landry ce qui est utile
c'est de voir que tout public peut
travailler et vivre ensemble qu'on rend
l'isolément à la fois des personnes
âgées mais aussi des personnes qui sont
quelquefois plus vulnérables qu'on
change le regard comme on disait tout à
l'heure des jeunes par rapport à des
aînés et inversement des aînés vers les
jeunes
je pense que toutes ces interactions et
c'est intergénérations ne peuvent être
que bénéfiques a à l'esprit républicain
qu'on aimerait bien voir retrouver
parfois mais auparavant la ministre
s'était rendu également à la maison des
sages de bus qui accueille des malades
d'alzheimer elle s'est rendu ensuite
dans une colocation intergénérationnelle
à versailles dans l'actualité également
ce nouveau pas franchi pour le centre
aqualudique de maurepas et d'elancourt
le permis de construire a été signé
vendredi par les deux communes
concernées par le projet il va voir le
jour il va voir jour en lieu et place de
l'ancienne piscine de maurepas à les
précisions de justin brasier casse talia
tel sera le nom du nouveau centre
aqualudique intercommunal de maurepas et
d'elancourt le permis de construire a
été signé ce vendredi 18 septembre
l'événement marque le début des travaux
coût total du projet plus de 24 millions
d'euros
ce projet n'aurait
jamais pu voir le jour s'il n'y avait
pas eu la confiance entre nos deux
villes amies maurepas ils encourent et
aussi avec l'ensemble de nos partenaires
puisque on a quand même été des
financièrement de manière très
importante
pas loin de 50 % de financement public
sur les 24 millions d'euros que
représente le projet on est enchanté
bien sûr aujourd'hui
signé un peu plus l'engagement sur ce
beau projet c'est à l'image des
nouvelles piscines qu'il va falloir
construire sur l'ensemble du territoire
le projet s'étend sur plus de 4000
mètres carrés avec cinq bassins sportifs
polyvalents ou encore à quoi lange
le bâtiment devrait consommer 20 %
d'énergies renouvelables il se veut
écologique est tourné vers le futur
cinq bassins tout en inox plus de
carrelage là qu'on aura aussi des
matériaux qui seront adaptés pour durer
dans le temps et nous coûter moins cher
en entretien et en fonctionnement et qui
rend aussi la qualité de l'eau plus
appréciable quelque part mais aussi avec
une capacité de filtration qui
pourraient être différentes
c'est un projet qui fait la somme des du
progrès
des différentes technologies pour gérer
une piscine ou moindre coût et avec plus
de qualité
la première pierre du centre aqualudique
sera posée fin octobre pour une
ouverture au public en avril à 2022 le
sport est cet événement attendu avec
impatience dans les yvelines la dernière
étape du tour de france qui a vu la
victoire du jeune slovène tadej pouga
tard s'était lancé hier depuis
mantes-la-jolie malgré des conditions
sanitaires les conditions sanitaires
actuelles le public a pu tout de même
approcher les coureurs et la caravane du
tour pendant cette journée le reportage
sur place de michael et demi d'euros
ambiance particulière cette année sur le
tour de france 2020 au départ de la 21e
et dernière étape à mantes-la-jolie
masque obligatoire pour les coureurs
journalistes à distance des cyclistes
pour les interviews un village de départ
clairsemée du gel hydroalcoolique
distribués mais les passionnés ont fait
abstraction de cet environnement pour
profiter de l'événement on avait été
frustré de pas avoir de vélo pendant la
période du gros navires us deux breaks
et du confinement donc un grand plaisir
un plaisir de l événement comme ça je le
voulais cette année un bel événement
un beau symbole très précieux
aujourd'hui en plus de ça c'est les
journées du patrimoine et le tour de
france fait partie de l'histoire de la
france
un contexte particulier qui n'a pas
refroidi l'ambiance sur la caravane
[Musique]
ici la centaine de caravanes y ait fait
cette dernière étape dans la bonne
humeur des défis sont également au
programme
cette célèbre marque de café réunit deux
clubs cyclistes locaux
l'entente cycliste vernouillet verneuil
et riel et l'entente cycliste du goût
d'année
les équipes se mettent chacune seraient
entre nord et ils vont s'affronter du
coup pendant 40 minutes et doivent
parcourir le plus de kilomètres possible
le public a lui pu voir les coureurs et
les stars de ce tour de france pendant
cette journée à mantes la jolie et
notamment le vainqueur de cette édition
le slovène de 21 ans tu as des jo pogab
chars une fois les présentations
terminées les cyclistes sont partis du
côté du quartier du val fourré c'est des
moments inoubliables dont les habitants
ça méritait qu'on se mobilise pour aider
c'est inoubliable pour nous mêmes et les
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle étape dans les yvelines le
département est partenaire du tour de
france au minimum jusqu'en 2023 et pour
tout connaître de l'actualité sportive
dans les yvelines rendez vous ce soir
avec le cetud sports michael et demi
d'euros reviendra sur les principaux
résultats du week-end c'est à partir de
18h30
ce week-end c'était également les 37e
journées européennes du patrimoine avec
un programme varié dans les yvelines des
balades à vue en cours sur les noms
féminins et des ateliers d'art et de
science à la commanderie à elancourt
retour sur l'événement avec marie pas
neutre à eléonore sinoquet
brassens dans les oreilles pour
commencer cette balade sur les noms
féminins de la ville guyancourt rappelle
que les journées du patrimoine sont
aussi celles du matrimoine ce samedi
c'est le quartier du centre ville qui
était au coeur de la balade
je pense que c'est un plus de montrer
que des femmes ont existé d'abord pour
des questions d'égalité
et puis remettre
à la page que les femmes ont fait des
choses formidables aussi et souvent
c'était sous le nom d'un homme
c'est la deuxième édition de la
promenade et la pluie n'a pas découragé
les visiteurs conquis par le concept
c'est intéressant de voir un peu de
l'histoire de toutes ces femmes qui ont
fait l'histoire justement de la france
ouais je trouve ça marrant de faire la
lave à la toule a fui avec les phares
appris c'est bien pensé lui ces journées
c'était aussi l'occasion de découvrir la
vie au moyen âge à la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines
grâce à un atelier les enfants ont pu
créer de la peinture à base de légumes
enfin dans la cour alors qu'istres de
l'alliance s'est installé pour un
concert de musique classique d'une heure
et demie pour nous c'est vraiment
l'occasion de mêler tout ça avec le
patrimoine donc c'est pour ça qu'on peut
avoir des ateliers de sciences et d'arts
visuels des lectures on a pu avoir des
lectures
samedi soir un spectacle de danse le
dimanche
le prochain rendez vous la nuit blanche
du samedi 3 octobre à la commanderie un
événement gratuit et en accès libre
et puis à montfort l'amaury et le rendez
vous était donné avec le patrimoine de
l'automobile des véhicules anciens ont
été exposés pendant tout le week-end
dans le parc du château de grousset avec
vous allez le voir quelques pièces
d'exception astrid bergère pour le
reportage du jazz un château un joli
parc et des vieilles voitures
ce week end la première édition de l'art
automobile dans le cadre des journées du
patrimoine a eu lieu au château de
brousse et à montfort l'amaury l'idée
c'est de présenter au plus large public
et pas nécessairement un public de
connaisseurs
concernant l'automobile de collection le
fait que l'automobile peut avoir une
dimension patrimoniale puisque si on
remonte au début du 20e siècle qui sont
petit peu les débuts de l'automobile il
y avait énormément d'artisans que ce
soit des celliers des carrossiers des
ingénieurs
qui gérait la dimension artisanale de
l'automobile les passionnés sont venus
de toute la région parisienne pour cette
première l'occasion pour eux de
découvrir ou redécouvrir des véhicules
rares j'ai remarqué le carré voisin qui
est quand même assez des voitures
vraiment très rare qu'on voit très peu
généralement l'occasion de concours
après moi à titre personnel j'ai une
préférence pour les façonne vega j'ai
remarqué la face elles deux c'était une
bande dans un état exceptionnel autre
véhicule remarquable la reconstitution
de la voisin qui a battu le record du
monde de vitesse à l'autodrome de
montlhéry en 1927 sa voiture car
entièrement disparu et j'avais un moteur
c'est un moteur six cylindres 1,6 litre
avec un pont arrière que je suis dit
tiens ce serait marrant de reconstruire
cette voiture qui a disparu complètement
donc on a dessiné la voiture d'après une
si cette photo un peu plus et après on
l'a reconstruite en l'espace d'un an et
demi c'était fait au total 2000
personnes sont venues admirer les
véhicules anciens les organisateurs
pensent déjà à la seconde édition qui
devrait avoir lieu pendant les journées
du patrimoine l'année prochaine voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]